في تصريحاته نقل لو سمعت انه انت قلت انه
انت ندمان عن دورك حاتم رشيد في عماره
يعقوب ينصحيح الكلام لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
لا انا ما قلتش انا مش ندمان على اي دور
انا عملته
مهما كان الدور ومهما كان الفيلم وبالذات
فمراه عبيان وفي الفيل الازرق وفي الجزيره
دي اعمال عملت لي خطوات لكن لو انكرتها
كاني بانكر كل اللي انا عملته هذه هي
الاعمده اللي بدات عليها
انا قلته بس اللي قلته فعلا لو انا
النهارده عرض علي الدور ده مش هاعمله يعني
هذا دور انتحاري تقوم به وانت على الحركه
همم اسمك مكتوب بالرصاص بعد
في البينه لم يحضر يعني ولم تتثبت في
المهنه ادور انتحاريه بالذات عبيان انما
اضفك النهارده لو انا عندي الجمهور ده
الحمد لله والبتاع ايه اللي يخليني يا
خاطر بدور زي ده او ايه اللي يخليني اخاطر
في الحته دي بالذات واحنا في المجتمع ده
تقريبا كان عندي 40 سنه وكان عندي اا
يعني ما كانش عندي كان عندي استبياع وكان
عندي برده همم
[موسيقى]
غباوه يعني انا اللي هيكلمني يعني
ومعقول حيث افتكروني كده وزاره
كده طبعا
لما كنت اسمع انه مثلا ممثل عنده بنات وما
رضيش يعمل الدور لانه هيعمل لهم مشكله في
حياتهم ايوه صح هو مش هو اللي انا بخترع
ده ولا انا وعشان كده انا كان عندي الظروف
مناسبه ان انا مش متجوز ومش مخلف مع ان دي
جابت لي كلام برده
اذا عرض علي النهارده الدور ده مش هاعمله
واذا عرض على الفيل الازرق ثاني
ايوه ايوه
مش عايز اعمله ثاني وفي شخصيات ما تعملش
كذا مره الشيطان اللي منحرف المنحرف جنسيه
خالص من الاول